Speaker 1: A very big breaking news. Donald
Trump, Ivanka Trump and Donald Trump Jr. have been
subpoenaed by the New York attorney general. This
is a we are talking about Letitia James, who is a
Democrat. Letitia James has been investigating the
Trump Organization for Possible Financial Crimes,
and we have learned yesterday that subpoenas have
been issued for Donald Trump, Ivanka Trump and
Donald Trump Jr.. Now what is that issue here, as
a reminder, is the what's the right word? I mean,
is it is it scamming? Is it lying? Is it's
the widely at this point accepted allegation
that we heard from Michael Cohen and others that
Donald Trump would lie one way or the other. The
Trump Organization would deceive one way or the
other about the value of properties in order to
achieve whatever goal they had. So basically, the
way it works is as follows. Imagine that you have
a building that's actually worth $25 million. Just
as an example, let's say you have a $25 million
building. If you want to get a loan and you want
a $35 million loan when the bank says, What's your
collateral? You say, I've got this building that's
worth 50 million now. It's really only worth 25,
but you say it's worth $50, so you can safely give
me a loan of 35 million against it. But when the
tax authorities come to you and they say, Hey,
this building, it's worth twenty five million.
So you're going to have to pay property tax on
the basis of a $25 million value, say no, no, no,
no, no. This building is only worth 10
million. This is a crappy little building,
and you argue that it is worth less in order to
reduce your tax liability. And that is, of course,
fraud. It is fraud, too to do that. And that is
one of the elements that is being investigated by
the Attorney General, Letitia James. They have
previously requested that Donald Trump appear.
We have now learned that they have
issued a subpoena for Donald Trump
and two of his adult children to appear, and they
have already announced their plans to refuse.
ABC is reporting eldest children won't comply
with subpoenas from New York. Attorney General
Donald Trump Jr. and Ivanka Trump are
now respondents in the civil case.
They have refused to comply with subpoenas issued
by the New York State Attorney General's Office as
it conducts a civil investigation into the way the
family real estate business valued its holding.
A dispute has arisen between the OAG and the
individual Trump parties regarding the subpoenas.
The document, filed jointly by New York Attorney
General Letitia James and an attorney for the
Trump Organization, said Don Jr. and Ivanka
will now be named as respondents in the inquiry,
which parallels a criminal investigation by the
Manhattan District Attorney's Office. As her
investigation into financial dealings with
the Trump Organization continues. Attorney
General James is seeking interviews under oath
of Donald Trump, Trump Jr. and Ivanka. Despite
numerous attempts to delay our investigation by
the Trump Organization, we are confident that our
questions will be answered and the truth will
be uncovered because no one is above the law.
Donald Trump Jr. and Ivanka Trump sought to
quash the subpoenas Monday evening in a motion
Allen feud or force. The attorney representing the
Trump children, questioned the motives. Her office
is also involved in the criminal investigation
of Trump. He wrote the goal of the subpoenas is
all too clear. She seeks to circumvent the entire
grand jury process and nullify moving parties most
fundamental constitutional and statutory rights
by requesting they provide non immunized testimony
to the Office of the Attorney General when they
and the District Attorney of New York are jointly
conducting a grand jury investigation. So there's
a couple of different legal opinions here. One
legal opinion is the ability of Congress
to enforce subpoenas is somewhat vague.
But the ability here to enforce subpoenas is
unquestioned, there is no legal question as
to the ability of the enforce the ability to
enforce these subpoenas. But at the same time,
they can show up and invoke their Fifth Amendment
rights. And there are some limitations to that.
One lawyer I spoke to said, You know, you can
really only invoke your Fifth Amendment rights
when it is reasonable to believe that speaking
could actually incriminate you. That there are
circumstances where what you are being asked about
could not reasonably be considered to incriminate
you and thus invoking your Fifth Amendment right
would not be OK here. It genuinely does seem that
they may have been involved in criminality.
And so the likelihood that if they were pushed
and forced to respond to the subpoena and
provide testimony that they would invoke their
Fifth Amendment rights if you asked 10 different
lawyers, there's 10 different opinions about this.
And so ultimately, we have to wait and see.
But much like all of the other things we've
seen so far, this may also get no traction.
But but. The fact that there were subpoenas
is certainly noteworthy, and over the next 24
to 48 hours mean we may well learn more about
the fate of these subpoenas. Some say the walls
are closing in. I still don't think Trump sees a
day of jail or prison. I just don't see it.
I'm not going to blow smoke in your nose or
up anywhere of yours. We'll have more coverage
of this on our Instagram, which you can find at
David Pakman show. Leave a comment there and let
me know if you think anything will come of this.